welcome to this video playing a Miss
shipped car not that's a new opponent
and again i'm going to ask myself why
ever not looked at a new line in the
room poo okay it's playing with dirty d
3 so don't have to worry about my charm
a choice on move 9 hmm ya know i should
play d 6 hmm ok it's not a not a big
deal but I normally play d 6 earlier so
that I have Bishop g7 after a four okay
that's not so good not so good in
comparison quite often you'd like to
have a move like night 85 against night
d 5 but quite clearly not on now now
that white has the a fried open you have
to improvise him okay I don't really
mind if he trades that should be should
be okay okay it doesn't so Queen d7
connecting rooks d4 I can take b3 and b4
with the night only three the push
deform it's not not so easy to play mmm
do I want to play before or not
so not clear sometimes it's good yeah
let's do that asking me about the center
no he takes interesting I can check with
the pawn awesome let's let's do this
it's that should be ok I didn't think
about that move at all that takes c3
Roxy 6 eb to getting this piece back
ride 2727 queen 84 that's a somewhat
annoying up I can go back to the eight
maybe
okay let's let's insert this and then go
back Queen a4 is really the only move
that looks kind of annoying but I can I
can retreat my night not that it is
great but I can to d8 it's there an
alternative Knight d4 I can just take
with the porn queen is protected
sometimes you can play this kind of
discoveries oh yeah that's nice
interesting idea activating the night
with the intermediate check so Queen a
497 lost would have lost the whole
position yeah now I playing this back to
ask him what his knights are doing
actually not sure how well they are
positioned here okay i can go rupee 7
there's nothing wrong with that on 96 is
also not bad I'm absolutely not sure
about those pieces here like they that
can be it can be completely misplaced
sometimes so g6 we can really take the
area okay d 4 I can take a form that's
not a problem
okay let's let's get rid of those get
rid of those pieces
just preparing g6 nidal e6 keeps stuff
together so g6 yes I guess so you will
go back to have three probably and then
we go from there hmm okay
now that's interesting move trying to
get at my pawns c7 and fsm yeah and yes
it happens so often I'm quite child on
time let's see I wanted to play see fire
but obviously not on he can go f5 but
this is not not a huge problem when I
don't eat six is a really really good
defender of NC seven first and foremost
I still want to go see five here and I
wonder how to get it in maybe I have to
go there first night be 64
yeah I'm close to getting c5 in I just
have to make sure that f 7 is not
hanging with check so let's see
also I might be able to invade them with
the rook be 2 or be three this kind of
this kind of business let's see thinking
bee three maybe just irritating white a
little bit time morning this is hanging
then mmm I always have seven is this
kind of kind of shaky what do i how do I
play him I want to want to really play
for Winnie I don't want to draw 40
seconds hmm
yeah no no this is a bit shaky yeah that
probably should have repeated also in
view of the time situation check
yeah it's very drawn with Shaq put 20
seconds but it's not so draw draw arvind
jump game drama and scandal far too hard
too hard to decline jam hmm ja difficult
I really thought I would be okay around
here I mean okay I probably was but but
nothing nothing more I liked my position
here maybe I'm just said just too
optimistic but I thought that would be
would be kind of nice around here but
it's difficult yeah difficult to play c5
and and get this get this going somehow
my structure is not not terribly great
okay it is probably equal computer is on
000 oops yeah you know computers had
this tactic this is something someone
when someone is playing this on you you
know he is either using a computer is a
super alert tactical player yeah d takes
Bishop C flat check winning the rook
or this one which is also a complete win
ah okay yeah and possibly i cannot see
that one it was again possible and she
I'm kind of here i'm struggling really
with no time on the clock the rook
endgame is probably a draw term so i
probably have to improve somewhere here
because when those pieces stranded on
the King side I really should be ok but
how I went through KH maybe this is too
lame the compounds to do this yeah this
is of course some this makes lots of
sense actually breaking breaking in the
center when these pieces are kind of
kind of stranded something something
like that hmm yeah that's maybe a slight
edge compass on 0.5 yeah drop probably
it's quite ok in this in this game what
can I do yeah thanks for watching